Speaker 1: So we're once again in the middle
of a climate change summit, and as is often
the case during these climate change summits,
we are starting to see articles outraged about
the fact that many world leaders and others
like Jeff Bezos flew to.
In this case, it's Glasgow, Scotland, to the
Climate Change Summit on private jets.
And the contrast that is illuminated by these
articles is, of course, about we're trying
to figure out climate change and yet private
jet on a per person basis.
Outrageous carbon footprint, a private jet
where you might have two pilots and a flight
attendant and two people or, you know, maybe
a small entourage on a per person basis, an
outrageous expenditure of carbon emissions.
And it is something that happens every time
there is one of these climate summit and it's
an issue and I'm going to talk about it, but
I actually believe that it's part of the distraction
from the real issue.
And I'll explain to you in a moment.
So here is just one sample article.
Around 400 private jets carrying heads of
state billionaires, business leaders and celebrities
have converged on Glasgow for a global warming
summit.
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos has 65 million U.S.
dollars.
Gulfstream jet was among the hundreds of VIP
jets reportedly carrying more than a thousand
attendees and their staff to the COP26 meeting
COP26 with others, including Microsoft founder
Bill Gates.
Actor Arnold Schwarzenegger also expected
to fly in.
It can't be stressed enough how bad private
jets are for the environment.
It is the worst way to travel by Miles, says
Matt Finch from the UK's Transport and Environment
Campaign Group.
The average private jet and we are not talking
Air Force One, emits two tonnes of CO2 every
hour in flight.
Private jets are very prestigious, but it
is difficult to avoid the hypocrisy of using
one while claiming to be fighting climate
change, he said.
For context.
The total carbon footprint of an ordinary
citizen, including everywhere they travel
and everything they consume, is around eight
tonnes a year.
So basically just your flight to COP26 is
two tonnes per hour per hour, and most normal
people consume, you know, about eight tonnes
a year in carbon emissions.
In total, the 400 private aircraft are expected
to emit 13000 tonnes of carbon dioxide.
But UK Secretary of State Liz Truss defended
the number of planes flying in, saying It's
important that we have people face to face.
I think everybody who's ever done a Zoom call
knows they're quite useful for some things.
But when you really get into crunch negotiations,
when you want to look somebody in the eye
and talk to them face to face, you do need
to meet in person.
So listen, I hate to tell people the solution
is not going to be to ban private jets.
So let let's take it piece by piece.
Does this happen at every climate change summit?
Yes.
Do people get angry every time?
Is there something legitimately hypocritical
about saying, We want to deal with climate?
But I'm going to expend a family's worth of
annual CO2 emissions just to fly myself in
this case to Glasgow, Scotland?
Yes, that's all absolutely true and legitimate.
But there's two different things that are
going on here.
First is just to kind of like a pragmatism
of the economics of private jets for these
elites, for lack of a better term.
Dignitaries, billionaires, politicians, et
cetera.
The economics of the private jet makes sense,
and it's been calculated ad nauseum if you're
a CEO and you've got to go to the airport.
Typically, the airports you fly out of commercially
are far more congested and in traffic laden
areas, and you've got to get there an hour
and a half before the flight or maybe longer,
depending on what's going on.
And then you've got to do security, boarding
all these different things, then get out of
the airport.
Just the additional time on the basis of of
what CEOs get paid makes it worth it to do
the private jet.
Now you could say, well, they shouldn't be
getting paid that much.
OK.
These are all debates we can have, but I want
to first start from just like a completely
pragmatic thing.
The private jets aren't going away for these
people.
Private jets aren't going to be banned.
I don't even know what the legal framework
would be to ban private jets like this.
Just this stuff just isn't going to happen.
We might want to do some of these things.
It's not going to happen.
So the solution here is not going to be to
ban private jets.
All right.
That's number one in terms of like the technological
question here.
The solution on private jet emissions is going
to be renewable fuels solar powered.
Planes prototypes already exist at some point
is going to be a real thing.
We have to be realistic as far as that goes.
I am 110 percent on board in saying look at
the per person carbon emissions for getting
these people to Glasgow.
It's obscene.
It's crazy.
It's particularly counter-productive when
we're talking about dealing with climate fine,
but it's not going to change now.
The more important thing is for me, the private
jet thing is almost as big of a distraction
as saying you should recycle your orange juice
containers and the boxes your Amazon stuff
comes in and stop using plastic straws as
a look away from the real problem issue, which
is 100 companies are responsible for 71 percent
of global emissions and you're not using plastic
straws is not really going to change that.
Reminder, The Guardian's been on this for
four years.
100 companies are responsible for 71 percent
of global emissions.
A relatively small number of fossil fuel producers
and their investors could hold the key to
tackling climate change.
Just 100 companies have been the source of
more than 70 percent of the world's greenhouse
gas emissions since 1988.
The carbon majors report pinpoints how a relatively
small set of fossil fuel producers may hold
the key to systemic change on carbon emissions.
We've known this for a very long time.
Even commercial air travel accounts for only
three to four percent of total U.S. greenhouse
gas emissions.
So here we're talking about private jets.
Private jets are a smaller emitter of carbon
emissions than the commercial airline industry.
Commercial airliners are responsible for three
to four percent of U.S. greenhouse gas emissions.
The private jets are a fraction of that.
So the finger pointing at the jets and the
air travel for me is almost the same distraction
as saying, you're not.
Did you just throw out that paper bag instead
of recycling it or reusing it?
The biggest polluters are thrilled to have
articles about plastic straws.
They're thrilled to have articles about people
or trashing half of what they could be recycling,
and they're almost as thrilled to have articles
about look at the private jets being sent
to Glasgow.
Are the optics bad?
Of course.
Of course, they're bad.
But the private jets aren't going away.
They can eventually be shifted to renewable
sources of energy.
We already have the prototypes.
It's going to be a while and it is another
one of these distractions from the fact that
unregulated or barely regulated or not enough
regulated major industry has not been told
by governments.
You're not going to be able to keep polluting
in this way 100 companies, 71 percent of global
emissions.
So I'm not laughing off the private jet thing,
but it's important to contextualize it.
Lastly, I also don't care that much about
the private jets if really substantive change
comes from the talks, which it rarely does.
Often these talks are, we all agree very seriously,
very strongly that climate change is a problem.
Let's get vague, maybe achievable, completely
unenforceable goals and end up putting barely
a dent in the greenhouse gas emissions that
we're pumping into the atmosphere.
So.
I really wouldn't care about the private jets
if we had something enforceable and more serious
come out of these talks.
The cycle is likely to continue.
It's not actually because of the private jets.
The private jets to me are more of a sign
of the gap between rich and poor.
Some people can't afford $400 a month for
rent.
And meanwhile, you have people flying to Glasgow
for the climate change talks spending 500
or a thousand or two thousand dollars an hour
in gas alone for the private jet.
Never mind the pilots and the airport fees
and all of these different things.
So yes, it's absurd.
But let's contextualize the absurdity if you
disagree with me.
Let me know.